if anything salmon make sure the scales
are removed super sharp knife let the
knife do the work
first off knife look at the gills lift
up the gills slice fill the bone half
way through and come down through out
turn the salmon around tilt it once you
tilt it okay he'll help knife to cut
through the salmon use your hand use the
tip of the knife hear that noise that's
the ribcage come down all the way
through clean the knife every time lift
up salmon slice through keep the knife
nice and flat but it's not flat
you know cut a huge hole in that salmon
now check what you're doing place the
salmon back down let the knife come down
flip through clean knife every time
it'll sharpen hold the head nice and
firm knife down in and through you're
very careful here not to go too deep I'm
using the tip of the knife and literally
just coming in and I cross that phone
see follow that bone down but the knife
gets dirty pull it out clean it come
back up hold the salmon nice and firm
now
let the knife do the work okay through
off now from there slice that off take
that off lay that back down I've come
through there I want to see our nice
clean carcass like that I don't see any
salmon left on there trim round the
salmon and this is where you take these
first fine bones out don't go too deep
keeping that belly on there so that
flavor is again clean board clean knife
you've got clean slices use the sharp
knife come through slice down through
the dorsal fin and remove that off this
is a bit of bone left on there come back
up in
and off remove the fin very carefully
every time you do this you're taking off
minimal cuts of salmon obvious reasons
and that over and then think about the
portions one two three four five
so we trim the tail there one two three
four and this bit here just tidy that up
a little bit
five second side clean the board down
same procedure again big knife round fin
come off nowhere near as many bones this
time round turn around look at the cut
mirror what you've just done there and
there we have two four six eight ten
portions of salmon fileted lines with
precision and finesse ten portions out
of your salmon understood yeah right
lobster first off off with its laws now
from their tail lifts open and twist
okay now open up add tail press it in
between your hand Parma ham in and
squeeze the top part that tail it free
squeeze once it's squeezed hold it open
and twist and literally do not burst
lobster and then when you get down to
the third one thumb on here push in and
gently
literally pull out the tail from their
claws separate the knuckle pull the
first floor twist and pull turn out get
rid of that water again separate the
knuckle twist drain out some pork from
their big knife hold up the claw in
twist burst off your finger in off of
the floor knuckles off there through
here slice one half down push from there
open up
beautiful okay one knuckle out take this
off these little beauties have a touch
of meat I'll show you where these bits
here top try slice at an angle rolling
pin at the back push and out comes the
leg these are tiny little legs but the
meat inside is so sweet it's
extraordinary
again slice at an angle open up the
knuckle down in and squeeze from there
take the head
cut senticles off as a V here go round
present your lobster take out that
that's just that touch of the carcass
show you why move that keep that nice
and upright there's a tail
there's a core inside before the claw is
each knuckle second knuckle touch a
below that is how to extract your meats
probably port loin on the bone secret is
now is to take that beautiful eye of
meat off the bone and cut eight
incredible steaks first off it's a
t-shaped bone there it's going through
as the blade there's the base that there
creates the most amazing cracking make
sure you stabilize again boning knife
super sharp really important will slice
through there come down off the back
slice through and start to open up
cutting in it's a little Ridge there
come over the ridge careful not to slice
through that eye fingers here it's
pulling back once I start pulling back
and I feel the lift of the loin of pork
come back down in towards the bone turn
the knife up in to the eye of the meat
you're gonna destroy it firmly hold and
slice down as you slice peel back I want
to see those ribs nice and clean once we
get there
it's a bendy flexible knife and is done
purposely for slicing follow the shape
pull back look at where I am check what
you're doing
stay accurate stay close to the bone off
now
loin bone from there you can see the eye
the skin we turn it over flat side down
come in to the fat and we just Pierce in
there and then thumb inside Nick a
little bit of fat through and literally
pull off now look at the eye remove the
eye that is the beautiful nut of meat
that gets crispy there's your cracking
from there it's silver skin of fat and
I'll go through the eye of the meat but
I want to trim this up pork is very lean
so you have to leave a little cap of fat
on there trim and then size up we want
four amazing cuts big knife for the
weight so it's four so lightly mark
there there and there
pushing with this hand to keep that last
slice super straight roll it up let the
knife do the work slice down off one
beautiful going to pork grip use five
fingers grip stop the wobbling on hand
on top there the knife do the work too
final size it up let the knife do the
work open up the fingers there come down
straight open one two three four
stunning loin chops off the bone great
sear and literally six seven minutes
three minutes on each side let it rest
you've got pork at its best right the
most important thing when cutting
peppers secure the pepper okay make sure
it's nice and stable so first off thinly
top and tail stand it up right clean the
board every time and then hold it
upright slice around try not to go too
deep into the seeds okay otherwise we
get that white part of the pepper off
and that's what turns it bitter
so keep the seeds intact now from there
straighten up your pepper use the board
let the knife do the work
one finger in front to behind this
knuckle protects the nail in slice nice
and fine let the knife do the work use
the butt of the knife and slice those
peppers nice and thinly this is how you
julienne the red pepper always cut the
pepper skin side down
skin side up really difficult make sure
those strokes are nice and in pin
peppers like this great for stir fries
great for salads from there clear down
next yellow pepper we're fine dice
similar way top and town again literally
secure the pepper up right so clean down
follow the pepper coming around don't go
too far into the center keep it nice and
straight that the knife of the work keep
the seeds intact from there similar to
the julienne cutting matchsticks all the
way to the end don't worry about the
speed be more precise clean the knife
turn it round uniform them use your
knife to uniform and then look nice and
steady on the handle
forget the speed that will come keep
them nice and tight like matchsticks
we've got a nice fine dice all the way
across lift up onto your board
green peppers this one's gonna be a
baton a bit thicker great for stir fries
again and great for salads great for
sauces clean the board secure the pepper
work around try not to take off any of
that white stuff inside so look I've got
white on my pepper there hold it flat
side down take the knife let's get it
off leave that on you've got this bitter
aftertaste on the pepper from there
square them up keep the knife nice and
clean at this time we got a bit thicker
flatten the pepper down and now we cut
the most amazing battle so we've gone
from a fine julienne to a beautiful
battle straighten the pepper out take
off a little ends nice thick slices and
there we have a beautiful baton free
peppers
three ways red pepper julienned yellow
pepper
beautifully dice and this is how you
batten the green pepper forget the rush
to speed all about precision
so first big challenge chopping to
herbes very fine
let's double for the chives secret here
keep that board clean stack the chives
these little tail ends discard okay how
many times you seen chefs chop a super
fine and the boards green all the
flavors lost on the board we want the
flavor kept in the herb so bunch up
3-finger rule one in front two behind
this knuckle protects please be careful
one in front that knife do the work
let's use the base of the knife and then
literally just pinch nice and find
they're called grundles because there's
a shape of a round cylinder now stop i
clutch over the chives and I'm not
pressurizing or bruising the chives so
as we get the maximum flavor in the dish
with the chives and I want the goodness
of the chives in the dish not on the
board and look no green on my board
superfine chives come on to the basil
open up the leaf tip the tip about 10-12
leaves maximum otherwise it starts to
bruise open up those leaves
gently roll them almost like a cigar
don't bruise the leaf clean knife hold
finger thumb three finger rule in front
and again let the knife do the work as
you see
the basil is not bruised is sliced super
fine
in the culinary world this is called a
chef an art and it stays a beautiful
color if I had to push my fingers down I
love what happens the goodness comes out
and there we have the most amazing shift
not just smell out the fragrance inside
there is incredible and look nothing on
my board clean super fine chopped chives
and a super finely chopped basil both
herds chopped without bruising there's a
big difference understood